president Trump's ambassador to Ukraine
turns on him Trump says he's the victim
of a lynching and the media proved their
leftist bonafide he's once again I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn comm slash Penn as
you learn on today's show it's kind of
important okay we have a lot of news to
get to here today yeah you miss half a
week and suddenly the world is new and
there are all sorts of brand-new news
stories that you come back and you're
really excited to talk about or
alternatively everything is terrible and
we have to talk about all the terrible
things that happen in my absence so let
us begin with improved 29:2 we begin
with the latest polling on impeachment
cake
according to Nate Cohen over at the New
York Times they did some polling on
impeachment in six swing states and what
they found is that there are a lot of
people who are sort of interested in
impeaching President Trump but not
particularly interested in removing
President Trump in other words they
can't want to censure his behavior but
by the same token they don't actually
want to see him removed from office were
a year out from an election according to
Cohen at the New York Times voters in
the state's likeliest to decide the 2020
presidential election support the
impeachment inquiry House Democrats
began last month but a majority still
opposes impeaching President Trump and
removing him from office according to a
New York Times Siena College survey in
the six closest states carried by the
presidents in 2016
registered voters support the
impeachment inquiry by a five point
margin fifty percent to forty five
percent but the same voters oppose
impeaching mr. Trump and removing him
from office 53% to 43 percent in other
words they're saying we have not yet
seen enough evidence to suggest that
Trump has done something so wildly out
of the box criminal that he deserves to
be removed from office and as I have
said before on the program there are a
few questions that have to be asked
about impeachment one was an impeachable
offense committed to is that impeachable
offense beyond that sort of offense that
other candidates other presidents have
actually committed in the past because
to impeach virtually every president
commits at some point in impeachable
offense because presidents routinely
violate their oaths of office presidents
routinely overstepped their boundaries
according to the Constitution it means
to take just a quick example george w
bush overtly stated when he signed
campaign finance reform that he didn't
think it was constitutional well he took
an oath to preserve and uphold the
Constitution of the United States it
seems like a violation of that oath to
then sign a bill you say is overtly
constitutional but was that really
impeachable not really it was just a bad
political move by President Bush the
fact is that presidents do things all
the time that violate the powers
delegated to them in an article 2 of the
Constitution of the United States Barack
Obama was droning American citizens
overseas controversial yes impeachable
probably not okay with all of that said
that brings us to the actual allegations
of account of offense against President
Trump and it seems like the American
public at this point are saying listen
we don't see allegations so damning that
he ought to be removed from office yes
they go to his fitness yes they go to
whether President Trump is a good
president or whether he's good at his
job but overall in today's political
landscape the American public tend to
believe that everybody is corrupt and
terrible and if everybody is corrupt and
terrible then by the logic of the
incredibles nobody is corrupt and
terrible right the idea here is that if
everybody is it sort of an equal plane
of stupidity corruption and ineptitude
well then that means that no one should
be singled out for a stupidity
corruption and ineptitude I really think
that's where the American public are on
this and I think they've been on here on
this floor for quite a while actually
according to the New York Times the
survey depicts a deeply divided
electorate in battleground states a year
from the election what the president's
core supporters and opponents
exceptionally energized and unified it
at the same time a crucial sliver of
relatively moderate voters 7% of the
electorate support the inquiry without
backing Trump's impeachment and removal
from office the findings suggest that
public opinion has actually stabilized
since shifting quickly against the
president in late September it leaves
American politics where it was for some
time deadlocked with neither side likely
to face a severe political cost for its
position on the president and you can
see why this is right if you're on the
right as we'll see in today's show you
look at the left you look at the media
you look at the Democratic Party which
are which is filled with partisan hacks
you look at the political landscape
where it seems that increasingly basic
liberties are being violated
they say at least Trump is standing in
the breach and if we're gonna get him on
these kind of ticky tack fouls
then what exactly is all of this
nonsense it's obviously badly motivated
on the Left Democrats are saying okay
well Trump is something completely out
of the box something completely new he
is running roughshod over the niceties
of the office and well we can't exactly
get him on criminal conduct
he is so just he's so wild and so crazy
and so he's not normal right that sort
of phraseology they use not normal and
thus he must be removed from office and
people in the middle seem to be kind of
like well everything both of you guys
are saying are true and so we have an
election like a year so we could
probably just do that that seems like
weird things dead now we'll get through
the testimony the Democrats are hoping
shift things in just one second that'd
be the testimony of ambassador William
Taylor bill Taylor it was given
yesterday behind closed doors in front
of the House Intelligence Committee and
it is not good for President Trump it is
also not completely damning a president
Trump in one particular way which I will
explain we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fun
and interest of finding out your
ancestry so I care about my ancestry
well I'm in Israel right I mean that's a
thing but you know the fact is that I do
care about my own genetic composition
I've taken the 23andme test turns out
100%
Ashkenazi Jewish I know shocker but the
fact is I'm the only person in America
who is less who is less Native American
than Elizabeth Warren is if you are
interested in finding out about your
aunt have ancestors III and me is the
best way to do it and it's not just
about ancestry obviously it's also about
finding out health patterns is about
finding out how you react to certain
substances how you react to alcohol for
example whether you need sleep you know
finding out more information about
yourself allows you to tailor your
lifestyle in a way that connects with
your genetics in a deeper way if you've
been thinking about buying a DNA kit now
would be the perfect time because
23andme the best DNA kit on the market
just got even better they've added new
features 23andme has now introduced in
ancestry and traits service it has more
than 1500 geographic regions a new
automatic family tree builder and a free
trait report the new automatic family
tree builder is really easy to use it
actually starts automatically building
your family tree for you using your DNA
so you have to dig through archives and
records for hours on end to start that
family tree 23andme will do all the work
to get you started the new ancestry and
trade service now includes 30 plus trait
reports for free trait reports explore
how your DNA can influence your
likelihood for certain things like
motion sickness or mosquito bite
frequency ancestry but you know
researching all this stuff it's really
important and it's really cool go check
them out at 23andme comm slash Shapiro
order your ancestry and traits service
today at
23andme dot-com / up hero 2-3 and me
comprar makes a fun gift by the way
gives people more information about
where they come from 2-3 and me.com
slash shapiro okay so today was
statements by ambassador william taylor
ambassador Taylor was the interim
ambassador to Ukraine and we know about
him because we saw him involved in text
message exchanges with other members of
the Trump administration including
Gordon Sunland who is Trump's ambassador
to the United Nations and Kurt Volker
who's the special envoy to Ukraine and
there are all these text messages in
which Taylor kept saying guys this looks
an awful lot like President Trump is
withholding military aids Ukraine in
order to get Joe Biden well as we will
see from his testimony he basically is
sort of reiterating and clarifying what
everybody already knew which is that
Trump was very concerned about 2016
election interference by Ukrainian
sources which again if he believes that
that is what was happening it would be a
legitimate thing to try to get to the
bottom of it after a low Democrat spent
two years trying to investigate Russian
election interference in the 2016
election and as part of that from claims
that has to do with Purisima it has to
do with this natural oil and gas company
that put hunter Biden on its board and
he wanted all of this investigated as a
as an investigation into corruption more
broadly Taylor is gonna claim that all
of this was really sort of a get Joe
Biden effort now that distinction is
crucial because if it was again Joe
Biden effort if it was really just Trump
trying to trump up charges against an
American citizen in order to knock him
out of a presidential race by using
foreign military aid then that would be
impeachable pretty obviously if however
this was all just Trump saying I want to
fight corruption in Ukraine and by
corruption I mean ABCD Prisma efg that's
a little bit of a different story and it
seems more like the latter than the
former but Taylor's testimony is is
damaging for Trump and damaging to other
members of the administration so in his
testimony he talks about a wide variety
of members of the administration who
seem to be going along with Trump's kind
of weird ideas about Ukraine I say weird
because there wasn't a lot of evidence
to back the idea that Ukraine interfered
in the 2016 election via CrowdStrike
there's good evidence to suggest that
the Ukrainian government was working
with Hillary Clinton to dig up dirt on
Trump right that was reported by
Politico in 27
so that's nothing new I mean that stuff
we already know publicly but if we're
talking about hunter Biden and Joe Biden
and burries m'a they're not a lot of
evidentiary suggestions that Joe Biden
was specifically manipulating Ukrainian
policy in order to benefit his son
hunter it looks more like hunter has
been spending his life writing daddy's
coattails which as it turns out is a
frequent practice in politics children
of famous politicians riding their
coattails to glory that sort of thing
happens a lot some in more corrupt ways
and some in less corrupt ways just
because you're a kid of a politician
doesn't mean that your success is due to
the politician at the same time if
you're hunter Biden and you've got no
qualifications for anything and your
baby hey fifty grand a month to sit on
the board of a company because your last
name is Biden it doesn't smack of the
exact honesty from hunter Biden in any
case Bill Taylor testified in front of
Congress today he says on May 28th of
this year I met with secretary Mike
Pompeo who asked me to return to Kiev to
lead our embassy in Ukraine it was in is
a critical time in u.s. Ukraine
relations
Vladimir zalenski had just been elected
president and Ukraine remained at war
with Russia as the summer approached a
new Ukrainian government would be seated
parliamentary elections were imminent
and the Ukrainian political trajectory
would be set for the next several years
he says I had served as you ambassador
to Ukraine from 2006 to 2009 having been
nominated by George W Bush and he said
that he had remained engaged in Ukraine
frequently visiting since 2013 he's
obviously very Pro Ukraine versus
Russian aggression outside he supported
stronger stronger American sanctions
against Russia
he said he considered saying yes his
wife didn't want him to because she felt
that the Trump administration was just
not a good place to serve he says I was
worried about what I had heard
concerning the role of Rudy Giuliani who
had made several high-profile statements
about Ukraine and US policy toward the
country so during my meetings with
secretary Pompeo on May 28th I made
clear to him and others present that if
the US policy toward Ukraine changed he
would not want me posted there and I
could not stay he assured me that the
policy had strong support for Ukraine
would continue and that he would support
me in defending that policy so he agreed
to go back to Kiev
because he was appointed by the
secretary but not reconfirmed by the
Senate he was the interim ambassador to
Ukraine so he returns to Kyiv and he
says as soon as he got there he quote
discovered a weird combination
of encouraging confusing and ultimately
alarming circumstances say he talks
about how he was hopeful about president
Solinsky fighting corruption he said I
found a confusing unusual arrangement
for making US policy toward Ukraine
there appeared to be two channels of US
policy making and implementation one
regular and one highly irregular as the
chief of mission I had authority over
the regular formal diplomatic processes
including the bulk of the US effort to
support Ukraine against the Russian
invasion and to help it to feed
corruption he said this is the regular
Channel at the same time there was an
irregular informal channel of us
policymaking with regard to Ukraine one
which included then special envoy Kurt
Volker ambassador Sunland Secretary of
Energy repairing and as I subsequently
and subsequently learned Rudy Giuliani I
was clearly in the regular Channel but I
was also included in the irregular
Channel he says the irregular Channel
began when ambassador Volker ambassador
sunland Perry and with Senator Ron
Johnson briefed Trump on May 23rd upon
the return from zelinsky's inauguration
the delegation returns Washington
enthusiastic about the new Ukrainian
president but president Trump did not
share their enthusiasm for a meeting
with mr. szalinski he says when I first
arrived in Kiev in June in July the
actions of both the regular and the
irregular channels of foreign policies
served the same goal u.s. Ukraine
partnership but by August all of this
was diverging he says that on and on
June 27th ambassador Sumlin told me
during a phone conversation that
President Solinsky needed to make clear
to President Trump that he president
zalenski was not standing in the way of
investigations and he didn't know Taylor
didn't know what exactly this was
supposed to me he didn't understand what
exactly were the investigations that he
was supposed to get to the bottom of he
said it was not clear to me on that call
what this meant but ambassador Volcker
noted he would relay the president Trump
wanted to see rule of law transparency
but also specifically cooperation on
investigations to quote get to the
bottom of things he says he reported on
this call to Deputy Assistant Secretary
of State George Kent who had
responsibility for Ukraine me said by
mid July it was becoming clear to me
that the meeting president Solinsky
wanted with Trump was conditioned on the
investigations of burries m'a and
alleged Ukrainian interference in the
2016 US elections it was also clear that
this condition was driven by the
irregular policy Channel I had come to
understand was guided by Giuliani now
Trump's defense to this is going to be
right I want all of the corruption in
Ukraine investigated including burries
mo I don't want the breeze my
investigation dropped because that's a
good indicator of corruption in Ukraine
that's gonna be Trump's defense the Left
Democrats are going to claim no the
reason that he was so all-fired too
concerned with Purisima specifically is
because he wanted to go after Joe Biden
so some so so Taylor says that he had a
series of meetings in which it was clear
that everybody in state and defense
wanted to resume aid to Ukraine but
Ukraine was being held up specifically
by chief of staff Mick Mulvaney and the
chief of staff maintained a skeptical
view toward Ukraine he said needless to
say the Ukrainians in the meetings were
confused ambassador Bolton and the
regular Ukraine policy decision-making
channel wanted to talk about security
energy and reform ambassador sunland
participants in the irregular Channel
wanted to talk about the connection
between a White House meeting and
Ukrainian investigations he said he had
a July 19th call in which it was
discussed that Rudy Giuliani ought to be
involved in this process and then he
talks about the text messages that he
held with other members of the Trump
administration in which he suggested
that there might be a quid pro quo going
on he says later on July 20th I had a
phone conversation with ambassador
someone while he was on a train from
Paris to London
ambassador someone told me he had
recommended - szalinski he used the
phrase I will leave no stone unturned
with regard to investigations when
President Solinsky spoke with President
Trump and then on July 25th they had
this conversation he says after our
meeting with President Solinsky the next
day ambassador Volcker and I traveled to
the front line in northern Don bus to
receive a briefing from the commander of
the forces on the line of contact
arriving for the briefing and military
headquarters the commander thanked us
for security assistance but I was aware
this assistance was on hold which made
me uncomfortable and they looked over
all the damage that had been done by
Russian LED forces over 13,000
Ukrainians had been killed in the war
one or two a week he says on August 16th
I exchanged text messages with
ambassador Volcker in which I learned
that Andre year Mac had asked the United
States to submit an official request for
an investigation into burries mosz
alleged violations of Ukrainian law if
that's what the u.s. desired a formal
request to the Ukrainians to conduct an
investigation based on violations of
their own
struck me as improper I recommended to
ambassador Volker that we stay clear by
mid-august because the security
assistance had been held for over a
month by note for no reason I could
discern I was beginning to fear that the
long-standing US policy of support for
Ukraine was shifting he told Pompeo that
he'd have to resign if the aid was not
restored ambassador Bolton encouraged
him to keep informing Pompeo of this a
bulletin obviously who was Trump's
national security adviser did not
actually want any of this going on he
said on September first three days after
he cabled Pompeo zalenski met
vice-president pence in a bilateral
meeting in Warsaw president Trump had
planned to travel to Warsaw but at the
last minute had canceled because of
Hurricane Dorian and he said that he had
contacted the Ambassador from Ukraine to
let him know that the delay of US
security assistance wasn't all or
nothing proposition in the sense that if
the White House did not lift the hold
prior to the end of the fiscal year the
funds would expire and Ukraine would
receive nothing he was hoping that his
pressure would sort of restore the aid
Politico then reported on the missing
aid and the aid was quickly restored so
bottom line here is that Taylor is just
reiterating a lot of the claims that he
was making in those text messages which
we have already seen which is that he
believes that the burries m'a affair was
at the center of this right he says
before the text messages that he had
with Ambassador at someone about the
quid pro quo he says during our call on
September 8th Ambassador Sumlin tried to
explain to me the president Trump is a
businessman when a businessman is about
to sign a cheque to someone who owes him
something he said the businessman asks
that person to pay up before signing the
check ambassador Volcker used the same
terms at several days later while we
were together at Yalta European strategy
conference I argued to both that the
explanation made no sense
the Ukrainians did not owe president
Trump anything holding up security
assistance for domestic political gain
was crazy as I had said in my text
message to ambassadors someone and Volk
are on September 9th on September 11th
the hold was lifted the security
assistance would be provided so that is
Taylor's testimony and Democrats are
jumping all over it we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about making yourself healthier so the
fact is that if you want to be healthier
you need to change your actual lifestyle
it's not just about going on a tie it's
about changing how you think about
things like what you eat about how you
exercise there's about getting more
information and learning how to attune
your habits to living healthier
well good
for you there's the service that helps
you do this that service is called new I
know they're great because I've been
using new them and they helped me lose a
little bit away I've not just lost a
little bit away it's also helped me eat
healthier it's also helped me keep on
track with regard to my exercise it is
easy and it is convenient based in
psychology Noom teaches you why you do
the things you do and arms you with the
tools to break the bad habits and then
replace them with better ones
NUMA is not a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life no food is
good or bad or off limits instead Noom
teaches moderation and can be used in
conjunction with a lot of preexisting
popular diets if you actually want to do
so and noon just asks for you to commit
about 10 minutes a day and that's really
all that it takes I've recommended as my
parents because it is so good you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps do make big progress sign up for
your trial today at noon and om accom /
Shapiro visit Newman comm / appear to
start your trial today that is n oo m n
o om dot-com / Shapiro the last
weight-loss program you'll need new mom
@ / appear o go check them out right now
okay so naturally the left is jumping
all over Bill Taylor's testimony they're
suggesting that it adds something new to
the mix I don't think that it does
actually it seems to me that the the
same thing is basically that it seems to
me the same thing is basically being
reiterated here that if you perceive
this as Trump trying to hold up a to get
Biden it looks like that and if you
perceive it as Trump very upset about a
wide variety of corruption angles that
affect him personally as well as
affecting the country and Rudy Giuliani
feeding him bad information Trump is
reacting to all of that and so what you
have is basically the continuation of
this Rorschach test that has existed
ever since the transcripts of the Trump
zalenski phone call came out a few weeks
ago President Trump for his part is of
course deeply deeply upset about all of
this and he is more upset about all of
this because he looks at the behavior of
the Democrats and he says these people
are not acting in honest fashion
representative Andy Biggs of Arizona has
a piece in the Washington Examiner
talking about the process being used in
the House he says that this is corrupt
he says earlier this week representative
Denny hat the Democratic member of the
House Intelligence Committee who told
the reporters that Republicans are darn
lucky these hearings and depositions
weren't public the implication was the
information coming out is horrifically
damaged
to trump the reality is if the
information was damaging to Trump
Democrats would hold open hearings they
would have already released transcript
of the testimonies Trump didn't ask the
Ukrainian president to investigate a
political opponent the Trump
administration has not really has
released the transcript of the telephone
conversation between Trump and Ukrainian
president Solinsky the Trump
administration will provide additional
evidence and witnesses in an open and
transparent process but why should they
cooperate when the fix is in Adam Schiff
keeps holding these closed-door meetings
in top-security room in the basement of
the Capitol he's doing this to keep the
public and the president in the dark
nonetheless leftist media outlets report
on the substance of what has been
testified to and what documents have
been produced in the hearings someone
from the left is leaking he says that
Pelosi Schiff
Democrats in Congress are ignoring
historical norms and processes in order
to try to remove Trump from office he
says we usually have a process in which
an impeachment investigation is
commenced by a formal vote by members of
the House of Representatives the
investigation is then conducted by the
judiciary committee or a special Select
Committee at the same time that the
formal resolution to investigate the
president is voted on the house
establishes rules of the investigation
sets the committee that will investigate
and any other particular instructions
necessary for the committee to do its
work but Democrats aren't doing this
instead they're doing this on an ad-hoc
basis and so Trump feels like he's being
screwed meanwhile Molly Hemingway over
at the Federalists is pointing out that
Adam Schiff is flip flopping on the
public nature of whistleblower testimony
after reports that he was coordinating
with the whistleblower Hemingway says at
first Schiff insisted an anti-trump
bureaucrat sharing allegations against
the president must share his story with
the house permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence
but after news broke that shift staff
had secretly worked with the
whistleblower prior to the complaint
being lodged discussions that the
whistleblower failed to mention when
specifically asked about them as part of
the official lore was the official
whistleblower process Schiff moved to
prevent the testimony the move appears
designed to prevent Republican lawmakers
from asking the individual under oath
about his discussions with House
Democrats media and others involved in
the impeachment effort so as she points
out Schiff has now shifted his position
on exactly what should happen with the
whistleblower should the whistleblower
testify should the whistleblower not
testify by Sunday Schiff was claiming
that
the testimony was not even needed so of
course from is going to be suspicious of
all of this I mean Trump has reason to
be suspicious of the Democrats the
Democrats obviously wants to impeach him
they've wanted to impeach him since the
day he was elected and he also feels as
though he has been targeted and
correctly so he feels that he is being
targeted by people inside his own
administration - the cheers of the media
and that's true he is being targeted by
people in his own administration - the
cheers of the media the evidence of this
is that the anonymous offer author of a
Trump resistance op-ed is now going to
publish a tell-all book and remain
anonymous while doing so and claims that
he is a top ranking member of the Trump
administration who's presumably being
paid a hefty sum by a publisher to write
a book about how terrible Trump is well
serving in the Trump administration well
if he doesn't like it he has a very
simple solution he can resign and then
reveal publicly who he is but he's not
going to do that well by the way we've
seen a bunch of people do this right
we've seen a bunch of people inside the
Trump administration publicly resigned
and say they can't serve under this
president well at least that's honest
what is deeply dishonest is a person who
is an anonymous non whistleblow right
not going through formal channels
writing a book for money in which they
discuss ongoing events inside the Trump
administration - the wild shares of the
media that's not good for the presidency
it's not good for the country and of
course it's going to underscore how
suspicious Trump is of people inside his
administration and it's going to
encourage Trump to set up exactly the
sort of irregular channels that Bill
Taylor was talking about right why would
you set up in a regular channel the only
reason to set up in a regular channel is
because you don't trust the regular
Channel one of the reasons you might not
trust the regular Channel is it feels
like the regular channel is being used
as a method of hurting you it feels like
members of the Intelligence Committee
are going after you I mean of the
intelligence community are going after
you it feels as though members of the
State Department on lower levels are
attempting to skew your foreign policy
it appears that members of the
quote-unquote deep State are going after
it's hard to argue with Trump about why
Trump should feel it should feel
differently when you have articles like
this from Philip Rucker in the New York
Times quote the author of an anonymous
column in The New York Times in 2018 who
was identified as a senior Trump
administration official acting as part
of the resistance inside the
Herman has written a tell-all book to be
published next month the book titled a
warning is being promoted as an
unprecedented behind-the-scenes portrait
of the trump presidency that expands
upon The Times column which ricocheted
around the world and stoked the
president's rage because of its
devastating portrayal of Trump in office
in just a second I'm gonna give you more
information on this anonymous book that
again is underscoring the president's
distrust in government which leads him
to set up a regular channels which leads
them to make mistakes which leads him
into traps which leads the Democrats to
seem to believe that they have material
to impeach all right this is all part of
a big big picture and if you don't see
the big picture you can't understand
anybody's perspective right left or
Center we'll get to that in just one
second first let me explain that my
sleep quality in Israel it ain't what my
sleep quality is at home one of the
reasons for that is because the sheets
here just not that great at least the
sheets where I am staying I wish I had
brought with me my bull and branch
sheets why because everything bull and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time you buy directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand dollars in the store
but bull and branch sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights there's
no risk and there's no reason to not
give them a try try bull and bran treats
I promise you'll love them we do we
actually got rid of all of our other
sheets in our house and we only use boa
and branch to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch com
promo code Ben go to bull and branch
comm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets
that's bol and branch comm promo code
Ben bull and branch comm promo club and
these sheets are incredibly comfortable
and they get more comfortable the more
often you use them which is pretty
amazing again don't get those those
sheets with the high thread counts from
a local gas station they're not gonna be
comfortable they're just tarps instead
go get really nice sheets at bullet and
branch comm you should spend some money
on trees but don't break the bank that's
why you should use bull and branch knock
on promo club and get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets okay so back to this
anonymous of whistleblower things so
let's say that your Trump like to just
get a man's head for a second let's say
that you're president Trump and every
day in the White House you see a story
from your administration leaking
something that nobody is supposed to
know outside the administration because
this is the center of foreign
policymaking in the United States and
there it is leaking and then let's say
that there are series of op eds that
keep coming out from
members of your administration lower
down members of your administration
either quitting or anonymously ripping
into you and let's say that you feel
like your policy is being forwarded and
let's add to that you believe that the
media hate you because they do and let's
add to that that it feels like major
companies big tech companies are biased
against you which in many cases they are
wouldn't you start to get a bit of a
persecution complex wouldn't you start
to think okay well whatever power I do
have I'm going to use to investigate
this sort of corruption because forget
me the power of the presidency is under
attack no one should have to operate
this way and there is this ridiculous
double standard where if you're a
Democrat and you're in power the entire
quote-unquote apparatus works for you
but if you're Republican half the
apparatus is working against you half
the time and that is and that's a
disaster area again this anonymous book
is really case in point
of this as I mentioned the New York
Times is reporting that there is an
anonymous anti-trump book that's gonna
be published from inside the
administration the author of a column in
the New York Times which was titled I am
part of the resistance inside the Trump
administration which by the way is
wildly unconstitutional
I mean to be part of a resistance to
administration inside the administration
you know you can you can quit you know
the other thing you can do can work
through official legal channels you know
what you're really not supposed to do is
go leaking confidential information on
the workings of administration to the
media that's not something you're
supposed to do
Trump lashed out at the anonymous author
after the columns publication the
president questioned both whether the
author existed and whether the author
had committed treason and he demanded on
Twitter The Times turn over the gutless
anonymous person to the government at
once which The Times of course did not
the forthcoming book will list the
author as anonymous although the person
does not reveal their identity in the
book they will discuss the reasons for
their anonymity according to people
involved in the project the book is set
to be published November 19th and the
media are really excited about all of
this the author is being represented by
Matt Latimer and Keith Urban of javelin
they're the same literary agents who
represented both fired FBI director
James Comey and former White House aide
to Cliff Simms for their memoirs people
involved in the project say that book
twelve and javelin have verified the
book's author is the same person who
wrote The Times column but they will not
sure the author's identity with the
Washington Post there is no modern
historical precedent for a first-hand
account of a sitting president
in book form by an anonymous author many
senior government officials have written
books under their own name but this is
something completely different the
author could have received a
seven-figure advance for writing his
books at Lattimore but a warning was not
written for financial reasons the author
sees this as an act of conscience which
is why the often refused any advance and
is donating a substantial portion of any
royalties to charities that protect
those seeking the truth around the world
well I wonder what that substantial
portion is immune is he keeping any
money how exactly is this supposed to be
working I mean beyond that there is
something deeply disturbing about
members of an administration writing
anonymous books about the administration
where you want to come out - the
administration quit your job you don't
get to take taxpayer dollars while
bashing the administration you're
supposed to be working for and all of
this is leading Trump to rant and rave
obviously just a day ago the Los Angeles
Times reported that President Trump had
a cabinet meeting in which he spent some
71 minutes ripping into the media
ripping into people who are criticizing
him he says the Democrats went crazy
about the report that he was planning on
holding the next g7 summit at Doral the
Florida golf resort that Trump owns that
wasn't just Democrats were going crazy
last week I pointed out that this
certainly gives the appearance of
corruption but with that said he said
you don't think I get enough promotion I
get more promotion than every human
being who has ever lived
I don't need promotion it would have
been the greatest g7 ever you people
with this phony emoluments clause the
president repeated his claim he had lost
billions of dollars by becoming
president he says I'm making a big
difference for the country so whether I
lost two billion five billion more or
less it doesn't make any difference to
me I don't care if you're rich it
doesn't matter I'm doing this for the
country okay well that may well be true
and the president also obviously feels
that he is under assault mainly because
he is in fact under assault and so he is
I mean right now he is busily
investigating the intelligence
community's actions in 2016 his own
attorney general bill Barr has been
investigating the origins of the Trump
Russia probe that ended up being a big
nothing
during the Mulla report right the Trump
Russia stuff ended up basically
amounting to nothing it was the
obstruction stuff that was damaging to
president Trump according to Politico
William Bar has been meeting with the
u.s. is closest foreign intelligence
allies in recent months making repeated
trips overseas as part of an
investigation he is overseeing into the
origins of
rusha probe and whether any
inappropriate spying occurred on the
Trump campaign as part of that
investigation Barr and John Durham the
federal prosecutor he appointed to
conduct it have been probing a
conspiracy theory for which there is
little evidence according to several
people with knowledge of the matter that
a key player in the Russia probe a
professor named Joseph Mifsud was
actually a Western intelligence asset
sent to discredit the Trump campaign and
that the CIA under John Brennan was
somehow involved Trump meanwhile has
been quote-unquote obsessed with Brennan
who frequently gets under the
president's skin by publicly questioning
his mental acuity and fitness for office
Trump has repeatedly attacked Brennan
public Brennan has repeatedly attacked
Trump publicly I mean Brennan has come
out and claims that there was
information waiting in the wings that
suggested that Trump was going to be
impeached over the Russia stuff and that
turned out not to be true Brennan of
course also allegedly lied in front of
Congress with all of this miasma of
corruption and ugliness and partisanship
floating around you can see why
everybody has retreated to the partisan
corners because nobody believes that any
single standard is being held on any of
this stuff if you're Republican even if
you think from behavior is questionable
you're saying to yourself with Democrats
impeach of this or Democrat and the
answer you come to is absolutely not and
if you're a Democrat looking at
Republicans you're like what Republicans
have impeached if this were a Democrat
absolutely yes so we're going to impeach
here right I mean that that's exactly
where all of this and if you're Trump
sitting here you're going listen I
always thought American politics was
corrupt and so I acted like I think
American politics is which is to say
corrupt right I acted in a way that I
thought was beneficial for the United
States in a way I think politics works
in a certain way governance is a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you believe
governance is an honest business of back
and forth you're more likely to govern
that way if you think that politics is
basically a business of greased palms
and people slapping each other on the
back in cigar smoke-filled rooms that is
likely the way that you're going to
operate and the fact is that American
politics these days maybe more like the
latter then like the former well get to
president Trump's response to all of
this and then he got himself in trouble
because he used a word word we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the amount of money that you
spend on mail I'm not even talking about
the postage like the post office does a
good job I'm talking about the amount of
money you have to spend schlepping your
packages down to the post office the
amount of time you have to spend doing
all of that instead
wouldn't it be nice if you could just do
all of this from your computer well this
is where stamps.com comes in we use
stamps calm at the daily wire offices it
means that I no longer have to
personally drive over to the post office
in the Shapiro household
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it is
indeed that simple stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm
right now my listeners got a special
offer it includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter Shapiro okay in just
one second we are going to get to the
rest of the reasons why Trump would feel
under attack because he is under attack
and there's some good new evidence from
steven crowder that election results are
being manipulated by big tech the
allegations he makes are pretty damning
and we have an example of the media
taking a story non seriously as long as
it is a Democrat that would be a
front-page story across the nation if it
were a Republican we'll get to all of
that in just one second first you have
to go over daily wire comm and subscribe
$9.99 a month we'll get you the
subscription 99 bucks a year it gets you
the subscription along with this the
very greatest and all beverage vessels
leftist years hot or cold tumblr it is
indeed magical we have all sorts of good
stuff happening over at Daily wire we
have a brand new daily wire app that you
are absolutely going to love it allows
you to have q and A's with me like I
will answer your questions in real time
if you're a subscriber you can access
all of our contents including articles
shows and more straight from the app all
of our all of our all-access subscribers
get our new exclusive discussion
features that's what I'm talking about
with the q and A's the app is available
on Apple and Android so download it
today become a subscriber come join the
fun
you're constantly upgrading the content
we provide to you it's really really
good go check us out over at Daly we're
calm and become a subscriber we really
appreciate it we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so just to complete the reasons why
President Trump feels unfairly under
attack light from and that doesn't
necessarily mean that his activity is
justified it's just to get straight why
everybody is acting the way that they
are I mean if we're going to explain why
Trump is acting the way that he is why
Democrats are acting the way that they
are why Republicans are acting the way
that they are and why independents are
just kind of going like guys can we just
wait for more information which I think
by the way is almost always the proper
response to nearly anything you have to
understand that if you're Trump you feel
like this array of forces is aligned
against you and you are right about that
right you have people inside run my own
administration writing anonymous
accounts for for penguin or whatever it
is for a shot about exactly why you are
so terrible without quitting while still
taking taxpayer money and being hailed
as heroes for doing so you have john
brennan running around running that
trump russia investigation while at the
same time for several years claiming
information that he did not have and
being a dishonest human being and then
you you also have the media which is
always going to treat you unfairly when
Trump says the media treats Republicans
unfairly of course 100% that is true
perfect example so there's this
astonishing story about representative
Katie hill Democrat from California
she's vice chair of the House Committee
on Oversight and reform and she is an
open bisexual which is of no relevance
except that it's very relevant to this
particular story photographs and text
messages obtained by red state showed
that representative Hill was involved in
a long term sexual relationship with a
female campaign staffer the woman whose
name is not being released was hired by
Hill in late 2017 and quickly became
involved in a throuple relationship with
Hill and her estranged husband Kenny
Haslam has leppe in the staffer
according to text messages provided to
red state believe the polyamorous
arrangement to be a long-term committed
relationship
the trio took multiple vacations
together including to Alaska where the
photograph was taken she was being paid
presumably on the campaign or taxpayer
dime at the time red state has obtained
intimate photographs of the women which
they've chosen not to publish according
to a source close to the staffer the
throuple agreed to continue the
committed relationship
when Hill moved to Washington DC on
January 2019 but has leptin the staffer
quickly noticed a difference in hills
demeanor
by late May Hill broke off her
relationships with both his lip and the
staffer claiming she wanted to focus on
this important work and it wasn't in
fair to be involved in the relationship
the staffer as the text messages show
was distraught trying to figure out how
to move on with her life now why does
this matter well because she's on the
oversight and ethics reform committee
okay like that that stuff actually like
this is an ethics complaint and if you
are if you are having sex with the
staffer that is an ethics complaint hey
her response by the way is is
interesting right her response on
Twitter was that she reached out to
speaker Pelosi and leader Hoyer
personally tonight in a improper
relationship with her staffer which is a
pretty astonishing denial considering
their actual pictures of the two of them
going at it I mean like one of the
pictures red state releases a picture of
Hill stark naked sitting behind her own
staff are combing her hair like I don't
know about your work relationships but
um that is not something that I do with
my staffers cuz that would be sexual and
weird in a statement Hill says she's
going through a divorce from an abusive
husband who was determined to try to
humiliate me she says I've notified
Capitol Police who are investigating the
situation and potential legal violations
of those who posted and distributed the
photos so yeah so she's trying to trim
her ethics violation into her being the
victim of an anti-feminist attack
witches which is interesting that Ryan's
Vedra over a Daily wire is reporting
that the woman is now suggesting that
she was involved in the relationship in
sort of an abusive way there's a new
report from red state which raises
questions about the possible abuse by
Hill toward the young female candidate
staffer gambits campaign staffer with
whom she was allegedly having a sexual
relationship the new report also raises
questions about the staffers ability to
give consent in the relationship in the
red states at Jennifer van Laar
exclusively reported on Friday on all of
this the young female campaign staffer
described the relationship as being
toxic she wrote Hill a message in June
2019 saying I'm terrified of pushing
back against you or upsetting you I've
seen how you treat Kenny I think if I
cause any issues even if I'm very
worried about how you were acting you
will quickly decide you don't want me in
your life and then apparently the
staffer said I don't know I was getting
ready I was think about how much Katie
liked to watch me it's okay she can take
this
mee-shee can ruin politics take all my
friends and isolate me but she can't
have this so then the mainstream media
have been ignoring all of this there's
been very little coverage of all of this
because of course this is a Democrat if
this were a Republican well this story
ever stopped being covered like ever
ever ever the answer of course is no the
answer of course and that is not even
the biggest story with regard to sort of
institutional bias against Republicans
today Steve my friend steven crowder the
comedian he has a new report out
claiming that YouTube actually tried to
suppress Democratic Hawaii
representative Tulsi gabbard's videos
following her feud with former Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton in other words
he's claiming that YouTube does the
dirty work of the Democratic
establishment now I know for a fact that
for a while there if you searched my
name on YouTube no result from The Daily
wire or ben shapiro channel would pop up
none and the same thing was happening to
Crowder as well I mean we discussed this
okay well now Crowder has revealed that
if you use a VPN from Spain the results
that return on Tulsi Gabbard are wildly
different from the results that return
if you do not use that VPN from Spain
Crowder tweeted a video according to the
Washington Examiner showing two separate
YouTube searches for content related to
Gabbard whom Clinton called a Russian
asset the first attempt was a standard
search on October 18th using an American
device which yielded several videos
related to Clinton's claim that Gabbard
was being groomed by Russian President
Vladimir Putin but none of the
campaign's videos the second search was
conducted using a VPN which made the
search appear as though it were being
conducted in Spain the search results
for Spain offered completely different
results instead the search showed
gabbard's own contents along with other
videos crowd around his tests again on
October 20th using the same search
method after the Clinton controversy
died down this time the search results
for the two countries aligned to include
gabbard's videos Crowder alleges that
YouTube is intentionally suppressing
other contents about Gabbard during her
spat with Clinton's who influenced the
2020 election Gabon of course already
has an outstanding lawsuit with Google
she claims that Google intentionally
blocked her campaign ads following a
presidential debate where she was the
most searched candidate Google denied
wrongdoing they said that they hadn't
provided incomplete they hadn't come
provided complete data with regard to
payment for the ads and that's why there
was this hold up bottom line is the
allegations themselves are deeply
disturbing if beg
actually has somebody with a button
who's actually pushing the button and
saying we are now going to silence
content from particular candidates
doesn't that scare you much more by the
way then the Russians posting memes if
you got somebody in beg tech who's
sitting there at any of these big tech
companies at YouTube sitting there and
during the campaign debates like between
Trump and Elizabeth Warren or Trump and
Biden sitting there and pushing a button
and demoting Trump's content isn't that
scary as all hell I mean no wonder Trump
is feeling under assault
okay so presidents from himself said
many a thing about this whole
impeachment gate 2019 situation he
started off yesterday by saying we have
an obligation to investigate corruption
in Ukraine again the two dueling
narratives are going to be from Bill
Taylor which is that Trump wasn't
interested in corruption in Ukraine he
was invested who's interested in going
after Joe Biden with American foreign
aid directed at Ukraine and then Trump
story is I'm interested in fighting
corruption in Ukraine and that
corruption includes corruption that was
directed against me in 2016 and it
includes Purisima includes all of these
things so why exactly wouldn't we
investigate all of that stuff we have an
obligation to investigate corruption it
was in my opinion that that's what it
was is corruption and if Ukraine would
know something about the 2016 election
you have to give that information I hope
that they would give the information and
everybody agrees with me a hundred
percent but when I look at experts that
are on your show and other experts
they're all saying you have an
obligation to do that okay so that was
Trump on Sean Hannity show the other
night Trump also added that it would be
great for him if the Democrats were to
impeach him that may or may not be true
if people think that the auspices are
strong from Pietschmann obviously that
won't be true but Trump then made a
statement that got him in all sorts of
hot water with the left he called this a
political lynching so he went on Twitter
and he said so someday if a Democrat
becomes president and the Republicans
win the house even by a tiny margin they
can impeach the president without due
process or fairness or any legal rights
all Republicans must remember what they
are witnessing here a lynching but we
will win okay so the word lynching
obviously has connotations that I think
everybody jumps to these days with
regard to racist lynchings of America's
past which are one of the most
horrifying aspects of American history
do I think that's what Trump was
referring to here no I do not think that
Trump was
the racist lynching by the KKK of black
people in Alabama in 1920 I do not think
that's what was going on here
I think the Trump is referring to the
typical use of lynching and politics to
mean any time a mob rule jury is sort of
rounded up and then people are unfairly
hanged I mean a bunch of people in
America who are not black for non-racial
reasons were lynched in the United
States for decades in the United States
so lynching does not only have the
racial connotation it does have racial
connotations it can be read that way but
it's pretty obvious that's not what
Trump means here how do we know this
well because Joe Biden said in 1998 that
the Clinton impeachment could be seen as
quote-unquote a partisan lynching and
then Joe Biden sweeted today impeachment
is not lynching and as part of our
Constitution our country is a dark
shameful history with lynching to even
think about making this comparison is
abhorrent it's despicable except that in
1998 again Joe Biden said that the
Clinton impeachment could be seen as a
partisan lynching that was reported by
CNN he said even if the president should
be impeached history is going to
question whether or not this was just a
partisan lynching Joe Biden 1990
so the point here is that the Democrats
were claiming this is obviously a racial
thing that's obviously dishonest facing
Democrats do this right Al Green said
that Trump should be impeached the
representative democratic represented
said Trump should be impeached just for
saying the word lynching well Al Green
also said the President Trump should be
impeached because he said bleep whole
country's about particularly like Al
Green basically he is he's just proving
the old sort of logical truism that the
last half of a sentence does not have to
have anything do with the first half of
the sentence right you can if you have
an if-then statement the then part of
the statement can be true even if the if
part is not true meaning if I say the
sky is blue if that's the conclusion of
my statement I can say if the grass is
yellow the sky is blue well that does
not mean that only on the condition that
if the grass is yellow this guy's this
guy's always going to be blue well for
Al Green the conclusion of the sentence
is if blank Trump should be impeached in
this case it's Trump use the word
lynching how dare the president
compare lynching to impeachment how dare
he do this does he not know the history
of lynching in this country at some
point we must say enough is enough at
some point we must move on to impeach
you are unfit to hold this office okay
so really like really that okay so even
raise your hand really if you believe
that Trump when he threw out lynching
he's like I'm just like a black person
in the south being lynched by the cake
like really you think that's what Trump
was saying you really think that's what
Trump was saying or is this just another
cynical attempt to manipulate language
everybody knows that went from said
lynching he did not mean the lynching of
black people that's very very silly yeah
but again everything becomes a
controversy these days because here's
the reality Democrats in 2020 are
looking at their field and they are
starting to panic there's an entire
article in The New York Times today
titled anxious Democratic establishment
asks is there anybody else quote when a
half dozen Democratic donors gathered at
the whitby Hotel in Manhattan last week
the dinner began with a discussion of
which presidential candidates the
contributors liked but as conversations
among influential Democrats often though
these days the meeting quickly evolved
into a discussion of who is not in the
race but could be lured in would Hillary
Clinton get in the contributors wondered
by the way
Hillary wants it Hillary's obviously
trying to talk her way into this race
she's obviously trying to talk herself
into this race there's just no question
right because what she what does she
have to lose at this point right she's
run twice she's lost twice and once she
won the popular vote her image is what
her image is in the words of a famous
woman what difference at this point
would it make if she were to if she why
not why not jump in you can see that she
obviously wants to do so over the
weekend she was at some sort of event
and she was and somebody from the crowd
shouted maybe you should jump in and she
sort of smiled and then ignored the
question she would love to jump in why
because this is an extraordinarily weak
field it's an extraordinarily weak field
and Hillary is obviously tempted to I
mean she's commenting more and more
often so she went after Tulsi Gabbard in
the weirdest way while I was on break
here right she she suggested that Tulsi
Gabbard was a Russian agent which is a
pretty incredible allegation to make
about a woman who served
United States military I mean last I
checked this isn't Kevin Costner in no
way out in any case
Hillary called Tulsi a Russian asset
which was odd I'm not making any
predictions but I think they've got
their eye on somebody who's currently in
the Democratic primary and are grooming
her to be the third-party candidate
she's the favorite of the Russians they
have a bunch of sites and BOTS and other
ways of supporting her so far and that's
assuming Jill Stein will give it up
which she might not because she's also a
Russian that's right yeah yeah she's a
Russian asset I mean totally and so they
know they can't win without a third
party candidate okay and then tulsi
immediately slapped back because this is
exactly what she's been waiting for is
that fight she says great thank you
Hillary Clinton you the queen of
warmongers embodiment of corruption boo
boo he's directly like the lengthy
monologue by the witch in The Princess
Bride queen of war mangas embodiment of
corruption boo boo personification of
the rot that is sick in the Democratic
Party for so long and finally come out
from behind the curtain from the day I
announced my candidacy there has been a
concerted campaign to destroy my
reputation we wondered who was behind it
and why now we know it was always you
through your proxies and powerful allies
in the corporate media and war machine
afraid of the threat I posed it's now
clear that this primaries between you
and me
don't cowardly haim behind your proxies
join the race directly and Hillary
obviously is considering that because
the rest of this field is unbelievably
weak Elizabeth Warren is weak she is
weak she released her educational plan
yesterday she used to be an advocate for
charter schools her educational plan now
includes a complete ban on any federal
funding of charter schools plus a
mandate the charter schools are supposed
to follow a bevy of regulations and then
she says that charter schools are
uncompetitive which is nonsense charter
schools are the only places where
parents can voluntarily enroll or
disenroll their children in the public
school system where are you talking
about I mean it's it's these candidates
are weak they're incredibly incredibly
weak and if you're Hillary you got to be
thinking maybe I ought to jump back in
okay time for a quick thing I like and
then we'll get to a bevy of things that
I hate a veritable cornucopia of things
I despise let's start with a quick thing
I like so over the over the holiday
weekend so on Sunday
dashana raba which is sort of the second
to last day of the fee of the Feast of
the festival of booths so that was the
it's it's kind of the day that it's
special day for prayer in Judaism
there's there's talk about Yom Kippur is
the day one you kind of absolve all of
your sins and then the gates of heaven
are closed and then there's more Jewish
thinking that says that hoshanah Rabbah
sort of the final day where God sort of
figures out whether you have repented or
not you've now had a trial period we
figure out where you are in any case on
hoshanah Rabbah
i ascended to the holiest site in
Judaism the Temple Mount it is allowed
you are allowed to visit the Temple
Mount if you are Jewish there is a
long-standing myth that you are not
allowed to visit the Temple Mount if you
are Jewish now the rules allegedly
specify that you are not allowed to pray
on the Temple Mount if you are Jewish
now that's kind of controversial in
Israel because the fact is Muslims can
pray up there Christians can pray up
there but there is an apartheid like law
that suggests that Jews are not allowed
to pray up there the Supreme Court has
basically already gutted that a little
bit so went up to the Temple Mount with
security and with a group of other
people and first of all the Temple Mount
is enormous I mean it's it's an enormous
enormous site and there's something to
be said about the fact that the holiest
site in Judaism now has a mosque sitting
directly on top of it but the let's just
say that the behavior of the Islamic
walk is bizarre so the Islamic walk is
the they are the guardians of the of the
Dome of the rock and the al-aqsa mosque
we sort of walked around the very very
outside of the Temple Mount producer
Colton can attest to this he was he was
there with me and as we were walking
around we stopped in what is sort of the
direct line-of-sight to what would be
the Holy of Holies if the Jewish temple
were still standing or third temper were
to be rebuilt at some point and so
you're looking up into sort of the the
kodesh could Ocean into that area until
we stopped and we took out our phones we
were doing a little bit Prag now if you
really believe that it is incredibly
deeply offensive for somebody to pray
not out loud right I mean pray silently
off their phone on a Jewish Hut the
holiest site in Judaism then I would
suggest you have something wrong with
you well the Islamic walk immediately
comes over and tries to shut this down
the police up top start to move us along
at that point it appears that the member
of the Islamic walk
decided to radio some people who are
nearby and a bunch of people came over
and started shouting Allahu Akbar at the
group which was really delightful one of
the members of our group was carrying
again I didn't run the group I'm just a
guest right so none of this has to do
with me on the Temple Mount I went I
prayed we were pushed off the mount base
achill II it wasn't a violent situation
or anything like that the one of the
people there was carrying a revolt which
is one of the sort of rituals that you
do on Sukkot he was nearly arrested by
the by the police the police then let
him go because people in the group said
listen let him go we'll believe it's
fine and as we were moving a bunch of
people came over started chanting Allahu
Akbar because it's deeply insulting for
people to pray silently on the holiest
site in Judaism it's another thing to
shout insults at people as they're
walking along the holiest site in
Judaism so they start shouting Allahu
Akbar
at people in an attempt to obviously
sort of I don't want to say say insult
because they're shouting god is great in
Arabic which is not quite an insult but
it's obviously attempt to provoke and
some members of the group some of the
more enthusiastic members the group
started singing back songs from the Book
of Psalms which of course is deeply
offensive right singing Psalms from the
Book of Psalms very very offensive and
at that point the police not wanting a
confrontation rightly so decide that
they're going to push the entire group
off the temple bail the point here is
twofold one the site's incredible if
you're ever in Jerusalem and you have a
chance to visit it you certainly should
it's the holiest site in Judaism it is
allegedly the third holiest site in
Islam I believe I mean I'm M'Lynn
alleged leagues I'm not in Islamic
scholar so I'm really not sure but I
think they say it's the third holiest
site in Islam and if you want to see
where Jesus walked this is obviously one
of the places where Jesus walked so it's
a very very holy site that's cool second
thing is it is absurd that you are not
allowed to openly pray up there they
should obviously be allowed to openly
pray up there Muslims not only are
allowed to openly pray up there they
have a Dome of the rock and a mosque up
there in fact I think there's a strong
case to be made that Jews should be
building if they can't build the temple
because there's the Dome of the rock
right there they should least build a
synagogue up there so you can have
regular eyes prayers if Muslims are able
to build a school on one end which they
have done it seems to me the Jews should
be able to build a synagogue in a space
that is roughly the size of three
football fields it is enormous but it
was definitely a pretty incredible
experience and the Kotel the western
wall which everybody always says the
holiest site in Judaism that's because
they don't
how they're talking about they're
getting it wrong the holiest site in
Judaism is the stuff that is above the
Western Wall the Western Wall isn't even
one of the original walls of the of the
temple it is an outer retaining wall
that was outside the walls of the temple
so a little bit of summation of what
happened on the time I was getting a
little bit of press coverage and that's
sort of what happened so obviously look
I wasn't there to provoke I I don't
think people in our group were there to
provoke but there's something wrong with
it with any law that suggests that I
cannot pray on a Julie Hall a Jewish
holy site that's absurd and people
should remember that when they talk
about partitioning the Holy Land because
it turns out that places where the
Palestinian Authority government governs
Jews are not allowed in and they're not
allowed to pray in any of these holy
sites and by the way they also deface
Christian holy sites as well so that
that's something to keep in mind when
you talk about the so-called peace
process okay time for a quick thing that
I hate so things that I hate today so
there is this story I want to treat with
caution because I haven't read the
entire trial transcripts so I'm going to
tell you what we know from media reports
and then I'm gonna suggest there may be
there may be more information I don't
know so I I'm only going to give you my
judgment operational on the basis of the
information I'm about to provide to you
again approaching it with caution if
this information is the crux of the
information if there are no other issues
that we don't know about then this is
one of the worst stories of government
child abuse I have ever heard of if
there's more information than there's
more information and again I'm gonna
pose it that way because I haven't read
all the trial transcripts and I think
that and I'd like to I'd like to have
all the information before I jump
because when you make a statement as
strong as this is one of the worst cases
of government child abuse you've ever
seen you want all the information so I'm
just gonna put that in a conditional
form here is the story according to
Amanda presto giacomo of Daily wire on
Monday a jury ruled against a Texas
father named Jeffrey younger attempting
to stop his seven-year-old son from a
gender transition being facilitated by
dr. Ann George Lewis the boys his mother
and younger Zechs wife with a consensus
of eleven of the twelve jurors the jury
decided not to grant mr. younger sole
managing conservatorship over his two
twin boys according to LifeSite news
they voted that the current Joint
Managing conservatorship should be
replaced by a sole managing
conservatorship but that mr. younger
should not be that person apparently
George according
LifeSite news George Ellis has been
granted authority to move forward with
puberty blockers which can cause
chemical castration and potentially
hormones if the mother so chooses
according to reporting from the Texan
this happened in where was it Plano this
wasn't exactly in Austin George Ellis is
lawyer Jess Jessica Janicek and Laura
Hayes said the mother does not plan on
giving James hormone blockers at this
time but no one has stated that she
would not be open to using them when
James begins puberty which would be
around 11 and a half for the boy with
the jury's decision mr. younger will
likely be forced to affirm his new son's
gender identity a girl named Luna so
younger did an interview with the host
named Luke Macy's and he said that his
basically his claim is that his ex-wife
is indoctrinating his child into
transgenderism is basically his claim he
is saying that when the kid is with him
the kid has no problem being called by a
boy's name acts like a boy doesn't want
to dress up as a girl then as soon as he
goes back to mommy mommy is pressuring
him in fact the father claims that the
mother is actually has been since at the
age of three withholding affection
unless the boy dresses as a girl right
mean that's the claim of the father
here's some what the father had to say
my ex-wife claims that James is a
transgendered girl and she has today
actually socially transitioned him
meaning that he wears a dress at her
home he has a new made-up name Luna
appears in the court filings he goes to
school the teachers call him Luna he
uses the girls bathroom at school all of
his authority figures his mother his
teacher librarian at school the police
officer at school the principal's at
school say he's a girl I'm the only
authority figure in his life that tells
him the truth that he's actually a boy
okay and afford that crime according to
the father the child is now being
removed from his home according to court
documents they show the younger son only
dresses as a girl when he is with his
mother who calls the boy by his trans
name and has even enrolled James as Luna
in school
according to younger James consistently
chooses to wear boys clothes violently
refuses to our girls clothes at my home
and identifies as a boy whenever he is
around him
according to younger the boy has already
been quote-unquote fully socially
transitioned the father noted in his
opinion
witnessed his wife was only giving James
love and affection when he was acting
like a girl she used to lock James in
his room and tell him monsters only eat
boys younger added he said every single
day you have to see her son sexually
abused and you have to maintain your
calm because the courts are not gonna be
fair to you the only way you can survive
this and get your son through this alive
is to calmly allow your son to be
tortured right before your eyes and
outlast the opposition that's what it's
like they're asking me to affirm out
illusion okay if what the father is
saying is true this is one of the worst
cases of child abuse I have ever heard
of is the is the court and the state
mandating that a father treat a
seven-year-old child who is that capable
of deciding his own gender that's absurd
that's absurd it's a scientific
absurdity to suggest that a
seven-year-old who doesn't know anything
okay kids are dumb to note I have a
five-year-old she doesn't know anything
you're saying that a seven-year-old
knows the difference between male and
female to the extent they're gonna be
able to choose their own gender for life
and that puberty blockers should be
applied based on the opinion of
psychologists who can't even define
gender or the difference between men and
women like this it's an absurdity it's a
moral abomination okay so if what we are
hearing right here is is the state
mandating that the father to give up
custody of his child because he wishes
to treat his boy as a boy and that the
mother because of her virtue in pushing
a young child to be treated a young boy
to be treated as a girl that that is
what the state now approves that it is
considered quote/unquote child abuse in
some way for you to treat your boy as a
boy and refuse to treat him as a girl
even though a seven-year-old says he is
a girl and apparently according the dad
7 role doesn't even say the girl the mom
says it's a girl that is it's hard to
think of something more evil for the
state to participate in than that sort
of abuse now again as I said at the
beginning there may be more information
here that I just don't know and I'm
fully leaving the possibility open that
that is the case so let that be clear if
however what we are hearing from James
younger the the father if what we are
hearing from from the father is the
whole story it's egregious it's
horrifying and the people of Texas
should be ashamed that this is happening
frankly okay well we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours or
we'll catch you here tomorrow with all
the latest updates we will be
broadcasting overlooking the Western
Wall in Jerusalem and see a little bit
that Temple Mount I was talking about
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]